this video is brought to you by Scribd
get 30 days for free by clicking the
link in the description below
BAM show vo was one of the most divisive
figures in history to millions he was
the Mexican Robin Hood but to others he
was a ruthless terrorist who killed
without conscience what is without a
doubt is that he rose from humble
beginnings to become one of the most
famous Mexicans in history playing a
vital role in the decades that shaped
modern Mexico in this week's by graphics
we discover the real story of Pancho via
there's a lot of mystery surrounding the
early life of the man who became Pan
trivia
most historians believe that he was born
on the fifth of June 1878 in the tiny
village of Rancho de La Jolla tada in
the state of Durango in Mexico his birth
name was Jose Doroteo Arango arambula
when he was a few years old his father a
goostin Arango died
this meant that Doroteo the oldest of
five children had to start working on
the Hacienda getting up at three o'clock
in the morning he had to walk her ten
miles to start work at five his work
consisted of planting corn and running
errands via later claims that he never
attended a day of school in his entire
life when not working he liked to play
cards and was often getting into fights
with his peers during his teens he held
a number of odd jobs including a mule
Skinner bricklayer and a butcher then at
the age of 16 he moved to Chihuahua for
work the story goes that two years later
he returned to his hometown in order to
hunt down a man named Agustin Lopez
Negrete who had raped his sister he
apparently found the rapist and killed
him this episode is said to have set him
on his life of crime he fled to the
Sierra Madre Mountains and joined a
group of bandits changing his name to
Pancho via the Bandit soup numbered
between 40 and 50 men raided the ranches
of the wealthy in order to steal cattle
and horses they lived in the mountains
and they trained as guerrilla fighters
their reputation as fighters against the
system established them as freedom
fighters in the minds of the poor who
gave them shelter UNS warn them when the
local police were moving in in 1902 via
was captured by the police according to
the practice of the times he was
inducted into the Federal Army he spent
several months in the Army and then
deserted heading back to the hills to
rejoin his gang around this time he
actually killed an army officer which
made him one of the most wanted men in
northern Mexico a reward of ten thousand
pesos was placed on his head Pantry
became the leader of his bandit group
and continued to lead increasingly
violent raids on the wealthy legend says
that he would risk capture by openly
walking through the streets of Chihuahua
to history money to the poor in so doing
he won the loyalty of the people who
helped protect him from the authorities
in 1910 Mexico seemed to be a model of
democratic stability Porfirio Diaz had
been the president for 30 years and the
country was celebrating a hundred years
of independence but Diaz ruled with an
iron fist and the elections that were
held every four years they were just a
facade in order to appease foreign
governments ninety percent of people in
Mexico lived in poverty since 1906 there
had been a number of worker rebellions
against the conditions that they were
forced to exist under each one had been
forcibly put down by the Diaz regime a
number of intellectuals began writing
against this regime including a man
named Francisco Madero he decided to run
for president in 1910 when his campaign
began to gather momentum however
president Diaz had Madero arrested and
thrown in prison the mock election went
ahead and Diaz was reelected for the
seventh time m'dear I managed to escape
from prison and he fled to the United
States from there he began planning for
the revolution meanwhile down in
Chihuahua pan trivia had established a
kind of reputation as this Mexican Robin
Hood figure a champion of the
underprivileged but he was also known to
be a wild man he was a ruthless killer
who had shed blood with utter impunity
seeking respectability he met with a
supporter of Francisco Madero by the
name of Abraham Gonzales
by aligning himself with Madero gonzales
told pan show that he would be able to
reinvent himself as a legitimate man of
the people
via agreed and he through the support of
his Bandit group behind this
revolutionary cause by now Pancho had
developed a strong hatred for the Diaz
regime along with the landowners and the
police who had been hunting him for more
than a decade
he and his men brought skills to the
revolutionary cause that had been homes
over years of raiding fighting and
evading the authorities in battle Pancho
fought like a man possessed and now that
he added an established cause he was
even more ferocious he also proved
himself to be a master of military
tactics brilliantly marshaling his small
band against much larger governmental
forces on one occasion of the Battle of
Escobar's pantry perhaps upon planted
sticks in order to fool the opposition
into thinking that he had a much larger
army than he actually did by the
beginning of 1911 though that army it
had groans four hundred people and it
was racking up to
I said victories over the Federal Army
in early nineteen eleven there was a
challenge to the revolutionary
leadership of Madero from the ultra
radical Mexican Liberal Party to put
down the challenge Madero turned -
Pancho who moved in and arrested the
leaders of the party
the grateful Madero rewarded via by
making him a colonel of his
Revolutionary Army in May 1911 maderos
3,000 strong force with Villa at the
forefront laid siege to the border city
of Ciudad Horace that town was guarded
by 500 federal troops along with 300
civilian auxiliaries and local police
the fighting went on for two days and at
the end the Federal Police surrendered
on May the 25th with his armies being
defeated and public opinion unanimously
against him president Diaz resigns and
fled into exile the free and fair
election was held in which Francisco
Madero was elected president Madero he
signed the Treaty of Ciudad Juarez by
which the Federal Army would remain in
place he therefore disbanded the rebel
army ins ordered them to return to their
pre-war lives Madero allowed the
structure of the Diaz government to
remain taband revered this was a fatal
Arab and he let his feelings be known
he told Madero you sir have destroyed
the revolution it's simple this bunch of
dandies have made a fool of you and this
will eventually cost us our necks
including yours
[Music]
Veon and his fellow revolutionaries were
also in sense that Madero refused to
distribute seized Hacienda land to
veterans of the struggle as payments for
the services they rendered via became
increasingly critical at maderos action
especially his putting a former
supporter of deposed president Diaz's
Minister of War even more outspoken was
a fellow revolutionary leader by the
name of Pascual Orozco in March of
nineteen twelve Orosco led a rebellion
against the new regime Madero called on
via to put it down despite being urged
by Orozco to join the revolt Spanish oak
Medes army of 400 in conjunction with
federal forces in a series of decisive
victories that quashed the rebellion
following the victory against a Roscoe
vias band joins up with federal militia
in the city of torreón in the state of
Coahuila the federal commander General
victoriano huerta de tested via he was
initially welcoming though showering him
with praise and awarding him an honorary
generalship but the pleasantries they
didn't last long with quite an accusing
poncho of stealing a horse with his
honor in question via responded by
slapping the general this was the
pretext that Quetta was after and he
promptly and via arrested and charged
with insubordination an execution by
firing squad was ordered word of this
affair reached president Madero who
telegraphed Quetta and ordered him to
not execute via but to keep him as a
prisoner via was sent to Belen prison in
Mexico City while incarcerated there he
learned to read and write under the
guidance of a fellow prisoner in June he
was transferred to a prison in Santiago
six months later though he escaped
jumping on board a train bound for the
United States on January the 2nd 1913 he
arrived in El Paso Texas while in prison
Pancho had learns of a planned coup
against Madero
he attempted to get a warning message
through to the president but it didn't
arrive in time On February the 22nd 1913
Madero was gunned down on the orders of
general Huerta the man who had come so
close to executing via just a year
earlier
Cueto now installed himself as the new
President of Mexico vo was incensed at
the series of events even though he had
become disillusioned with his actions
upon gaining power he still viewed
Madero as the apostle of democracy and
his personal role model now that wetter
his personal enemy
in power he knew that he had to return
to Mexico he indeed felt that the mantle
of completing the dream of democracy the
Madeira had instilled in him was now
upon his shoulders okay so now just
before we get into vias really brutal
phase of life it's time for me to
quickly tell you about scripts script
provide you with a huge library of books
audio books magazines and other reading
material they allow you access to an
unlimited number of these every month I
actually had a membership to scripts
before they even came on board as a
sponsor for this show as I made a commit
to read more in 2019 specifically I said
that I wanted to finish 20 non-fiction
books this year so Scribd with that
unlimited plan it's perfect for my goal
also I'm reading more magazines time
Macworld ink it's incredible what you
can get for any $8.99 a month I don't
really know how they do it for any $8.99
a month because I certainly feel that
books are more expensive than that
audiobooks certainly are
I even think some magazines probably
more expensive than $8 a month so I tell
how they do it but it's a good deal now
a book that was essential in creating
this video was the mega in-depth the
life and times of Pancho Villa's you can
grab that on script if you want more or
personally I've been reading a book
called the innovators which is entirely
unrelated to this video but it's
actually amazing and I couldn't not
bring it up like I said I'm trying to
read 20 books and this is one of them
it's all about people who created the
internet and computers the innovators
you can probably see where the title
comes from like I say it's not related
at all I just couldn't not mention it
you can read that book all the Panch
reveal one you can find a link to do
that below through that link you get 30
days for free and like I say you can get
any book you want just why not and
thanks to script for sponsoring this
video
man let's get back into it
[Music]
except for the wealthy businessman who
were sort of relieved by this return to
order the vast majority viewed Quetta as
a jackal who had stolen the presidency
in march of 1913 pan revere returned to
mexico intent on avenging the murder of
Madero and relieving his country of the
tyranny of Quetta he later recalled that
night I had eight men with me and we had
no definite plan but had decided to make
for my old haunts in the Sierra Madre
Mountains where I knew I could find men
to follow me we had one sack of flour
two small packages of coffee and some
salt that was all our food supply of
course we were all well armed but had
little ammunition via small bands began
making lightning raids upon the federal
forces that were garrisoned in northern
Mexican towns and forts slowly they were
able to accumulate the arms and supplies
that they need it within a week vias
bands had grown to more than a hundred
men and within three months it had
morphed into a legitimate army of
eighteen thousand troops in battle via
proved to be ruthless his standard
policy was to kill prisoners a lucky few
would only be spared by the intervention
of his left hands in contrast to this
brutal side of his nature though Pancho
had a strong social conscience for two
months in 1913 he held the position of
governor of Chihuahua he expropriated
lands from the wealthy to distribute to
the poor opened at several schools and
enacted laws to protect widows and
orphans on Christmas Day 1913 he
gathered the poor of Chihuahua together
and gave them each 15 pesos by such
actions he became the hero and the
savior of the underclass by 1914 there
had control over the northern part of
Mexico handing over the governorship to
his left tenant he began the march south
to Mexico City where Quetta sat in the
presidential chair as he swept Southie
conquered everything in his way gaining
a reputation as the center of the north
by June his army had grown to 50,000
most of whom were riding on horseback by
now it was a fully fledged army with
mobile hospitals and recruits from other
countries including the United States at
the head of this the largest
Revolutionary Army in the history of the
Americas stood Pantera via a leader with
great charisma who at the same time and
the respect and fear of his men via
developed a military strategy that
proved enormously success
day and night he would pour a continuous
frontal assault against the enemy line
supported by cavalry troops the attacks
were continually rolling with troops of
the Front's being replaced by those
behind this gave the defenders no time
to rest resulting in them almost always
being overwhelmed by this sustained form
of attack they are also established
officers within his army is similar to
governmental departments he had an
office of Foreign Affairs who were
particularly focused on reaching out to
President Woodrow Wilson for US aid his
financial committee made contact with
wealthy landowners to assure them that
they would not be mistreated once
victory was achieved the United States
provided aid to the revolutionary cause
three around about means via sold
livestock and other products to the US
which provided the funds with which to
purchase American weapons and ammunition
it was this flow of weaponry that
enabled the rebel army to match up to
the federal forces in recognition of the
aid being received from north of the
border there ensured that no American
property was confiscated positive press
in the American media resulted with the
Washington Times reporting in January of
1914 that via is carrying on a campaign
of modern and humane warfare the media
they sort of fell in love with via with
one editor writing via is without the
possibility of any doubt the greatest
leader Mexico has ever had his method of
fighting is astonishingly like
Napoleon's via instituted some telling
innovations in Mexican warfare he was
the first to leave the women and
children behind and forced the pace of
his army with raids marching far away
from his face he would abandon his
supply trains and head far out in search
of the enemy he was also the first to
stage nighttime attacks which became
especially devastating to the enemy
in the spring of 1914 the two key cities
of torreón and Zacchaeus were taken
these victories brought the regime to
its knees with Quetta fleeing into exile
on July the 14th 1914 the Federal Army
collapsed leaving the revolutionaries to
fill the vacuum into the presidency now
stepped Venice Tiano Carranza a former
Hacienda owner who brought his forces
into Mexico City ahead of via it was
Patrick Lee who was the hero of the
revolution wherever he went people would
yell out via their
[Applause]
via and his fellow revolutionary leader
Emiliano Zapata joined forces to oust
Carranza who they had never intended to
take the helm on December the 6th 1914
the road at the head of 50,000 men
alongside Zapata with his 15,000 by then
Carranza hoods naturally fled the
capital and Revere was now at the height
of its power wearing a navy blue suit
and a cap with the Eagle of the Mexican
flag on it he rode through the city as
the masses turned out to shower him with
praise he went to the presidential
palace and sat on the presidential chair
but only long enough to have his picture
taken he never served as the president
of Mexico although he could have easily
won an election at that time a council
between the various fighting factions
failed to bring a consensus and via
continued to lead his army against
pockets of rebellion Alvaro Obregon was
a supporter of Carranza who won a series
of decisive battles against vias army
Pancho was outsmarted by Obregon and
many of his men were killed he was
forced to retreat to his base in the
northern Sierra Madre Mountains in a few
months of fierce fighting the invincible
army that had marched into Mexico City
had been reduced to a ragtag mob of just
a few hundred men
[Music]
a change now came over poncho via his
violence shriek it was fully Unleashed
in san pedro de la cueva he brought all
of the men in town into the middle of
the town and killed them all personally
shooting the local priest in the head
then in santa isabela he shot several
american miners the americans they now
distance themselves from viren's
recognized the reinstituted Carranza
government at around 4:00 in the morning
on March the 9th 1916 via then since the
President Wilson had legitimized the
Carranza government led a force of 100
men across the border into the town of
Columbus New Mexico they attacked the
town of 600 inhabitants from four
directions shooting indiscriminately as
well as looting and burning buildings
via however had chosen the wrong town
the thirteenth u.s. cavalry was
stationed there with four machine guns
and four hundred highly trained soldiers
the majority of his men were killed but
vir managed to get away leaving a trail
of destruction in its wake
the American response to the unprovoked
Columbus attack was an overwhelming ten
thousand troops being sent on trains
south of the border with the single
objective of capturing Pancho via at the
head of the American forces was John
Pershing who led his troops along with
Apache Indian scouts through Indra of
fifty miles across the border in search
of via into every village that he went
Pershing would yell out where is Pancho
Villa every time though the locals would
provide him with false information on
several occasions portions of Pershing's
army skirmished with vir and his tiny
bands on one occasion Pancho was shot in
the leg in April American newspapers
actually reported that he had died as a
result of the leg being infected the
reality though was that Patrick was
still very much alive though badly
wounded and hiding out in a cave in the
Sierra Madres Pershing's expedition he
managed to capture weaponry and horses
but it failed in its objective of
bringing Pancho in with the Americans
having withdrawn via reverted to his
guerrilla fighting ways he still met the
support of the people and was determined
to continue fighting against Carranza's
regime then in 1920 with another coup in
the offing President Carranza was killed
as he fled to the Gulf of Mexico with
the national treasure
they had saw this turn of events as his
opportunity to come to a peace
settlement with a new regime he rode for
13 days to a city where he telegraphed
the new president at
for de loja requesting an amnesty quota
aggrieved grateful that the threat of a
via overthrow was nullified
[Music]
vo was given a 25,000 acre farm in
Canada you the brought 200 of his men
with him who immediately got to work on
improving the rundown property in a
short amount of time this area was
turned into a communist had a school and
it grew wheat and corn and bean crops
that were able to support the large
community via got up each day to
supervise the work and spend time in the
schoolhouse he hardly ever left the farm
because he was fearful of being
assassinated on the morning of July the
20th 1923 via did leave his ranch
he went to Parral to visit one of his
wives and to withdraw money to pay as
workers as his dodge vehicle was driving
through a deserted part of town
dozens of snipers opened up filling the
car with more than 40 bullet holes nine
of these bullets they entered Pancho
Villa's body his death was instantaneous
yet even in death Fiat did not find
peace three years after his burial in
Parral his tomb was ransacked and the
corpse was removed with head being cut
off souvenir hunters also took pieces of
the coffin and some of his bones in 2010
The Wall Street Journal reported that
his right index finger was being offered
at a pawn shop in El Paso the asking
price $9,500 so I really hope you found
that video interesting if you did please
do give us a thumbs up below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this several times a
week also check out our fantastic
sponsor Scribd there's a link to them in
the description below and as always
thank you for watching
[Music]
you